just come over from the senate i will
first read the chairman's script
as required by law as chair of the house
education committee i find that due to
the state of the emergency declared by
the governor as a result
of the covenant 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice was complies with house rules
and rsa
91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i will i want to introduce the staff
that assisting us today with this
meeting jennifer iv
is our committee researcher please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
representation thank you good morning
everyone
representative cordelli you're in the
mid room
representative baum here in the
committee room representative
here in the committee room
representative
representative moffitt here in the
committee room
yeah i'm here here at home in east
kingston
representative andres here home alone in
salisbury
remember home alone in chester
in my office
sorry about that home in derry um i have
uh kids sleeping in the house and i may
have some family coming in and out from
here representative shaw here in the
committee room
president cornell here home alone in
manchester
tanner
representative allison i'm here home
alone in concord
president here still
in the chile basement
representative i am here i am home alone
in jaffrey new hampshire
woodcock here in santa clara new
hampshire my wife is in the house and my
dog will
definitely be barking over i'm zach
flatt
from
okay so what we'll do is we'll go ahead
our first bill to discuss today is
senate bill
19. this is an act relative to the
degree granting authority of sigmund
university
and it looks like we have senator ward
uh
in the queue here yep i've promoted her
to panelists
good morning senator ward good morning
i'm ruth ford senator for district 8.
good morning mr chair and honorable
members
of the education committee i will
introduce
sb19 which will authorize sigmund
university to grant
degrees sb19 is very similar to
hb513 which will be heard in the senate
today
signum university is a totally online
degree program
which can be done part or full time
it focuses on language art and
literature
plus other sophisticated programs such
as the study of hobbit
the cost is low and scholarship
opportunities
are available sigmund university has
already received approval from the new
hampshire board
of higher education sb 19
passed the senate floor last month 20 to
4.
legislative approval is the next step in
the accreditation process
i'm asking for your approval of this
bill which be
will be a big help particularly to
teachers who are pursuing
further education thank you for taking
my testimony
thank you very much senator ward are
there any questions for
senator ward
[Music]
i don't see any hands up senator you got
off easy
thank you you're welcome
okay next next we have uh rep
horrigan welcome to education go ahead
please oh welcome it's good to be back
so my name is timothy oregon i represent
bradford county
district six which is the towns of
durham and madbury and um i
sent you i got way ahead of myself to
send you some written testimony um
a few days ago probably so long ago
you've all probably already read it and
forgotten about it
and um i was uh so i'm certainly
in favor of itla spell i think it's uh
he's i think it's a bad idea i do feel a
little bit sympathetic towards dr olsen
the finder of it because our backgrounds
are somewhere i have a uh
finally went as far as a masters by
masters in um
english comparative literature from
columbia university and he managed to uh
stick it out for doctorate um
and you know i think in medieval
literature so
certainly hats off to that he certainly
is a uh he must be a brilliant guy
to have done all that and it is an
interesting uh
enterprise but i don't think it's really
a university or that it should be
granted degree
uh granting a status so he's failed to
demonstrate his degrees are worth
anything and it's also unclear if it's
making any progress
towards becoming accredited or to
qualifying for federal student loan
programs he does uh
website says let's say something about
how they have their own financing set up
but
uh it would be better to do it through
the federal
program which offers a lot more
protections to both the lender and the
borrower
it has um i understand it doesn't need a
campus and campuses are very expensive
because it's offering all the classes
online but it's only
physical nexus it's a private mailbox at
the ups store the strip mall
in nashua excuse me university needs
more of a uh
physical presence than that or actually
they have to discover they have like a
second mailbox at the second upstart
bedford but that
kind of makes it seem even more
substantial if they have multiple
mailboxes um i was also troubled uh
dr olson the founder was publicly
threatening a member of this committee
apparently because he
didn't like a committee report with
take place in the house calendar in 2019
the committee report
i saw nothing wrong with the committee
report and even if it was that's not
really the proper way
for dr johnson to disagree with the
committee report um
and then they've also already been
advertising and actively offering a
master's
of arts degree which requires some
legislature and the
uh department of education have not yet
granted an authority to uh to offer and
of course it's not accredited too so
even at the previous hearing this
committee for the other bill hb 513 the
reason the lumber stepped forward and
she had used her degree to get a job at
a local community college and
yeah she uh you know she just said
flatly said she had a master's degree
from cigna man of course that
really didn't exist yet they weren't
authorized to offer events she appeared
to be
far as i could tell dedicated and
skilled educator but
there's certainly a lot of potential for
abuse if you have an organization
offering you know what are basically uh
fictitious uh graduate degrees
and um um and uh
also here's dr olson he's operating
obviously fair use allows
him to use a tolkien estate's uh
copyright for for educational use but
he's describing himself as the
tokyo professor he has um well not
really the degree of course his broad
arrangement but he has
other courses he offers which are
entirely about tolkien's work and
although he doesn't need his permission
that seems a little uh
misleading i think he's crossed rather
blurry lines so i certainly um
certainly think it's an interesting
enterprise i just don't
think it's at the point yet where we
should call the university or where
the state of new hampshire should be
authorizing it to offer degrees so um
so even though he's a fellow columbia
man i'm going to recommend that you uh
find sp 19 and expedia to legislate
first notwithstanding the fact we've
already
house has already passed the other bill
which is on its way to the senate later
today but
i'm so not sure what would affect an itl
on this bill
would happen i urge you to uh urge you
to correct the mistake we made last time
and find sb 19 and expedia to legislate
so
thanks very much i guess i'd be happy to
take any questions um
thank you very much representative
oregon are there any questions for
representative morgan
not seeing your hands thank you very
much all right thank you
thanks
okay next we have uh corey olson
um i'm just signed up to be here to
answer any questions that anyone might
have i don't have any further
to add to my previous testimony in our
previous discussion on this bill
but i just wanted to show up to make
sure to get the opportunity to answer
questions that people might have
thank you very much are there any
questions
or discussion for mr olsen
not seeing any hands up in here thank
you very much
okay so that's all we had signed up to
testify
uh would you like me to read off the
total numbers
okay um so we had six supporting
22 oppose zero neutral
thank you very much so with that i'm
going to close the hearing for
uh sb 19. thank you
is sb 20. this is an act
relative to one-year certificate
explain something to me because i don't
understand um
why why is sb 19 and
bills that we've already had and gone
over came back which doesn't appear to
be any major change there's a reason or
i just don't understand the process so
what's your question please explain that
real quick i'm trying to understand
learn the process i don't understand why
a senate bill is very similar to what we
it's required by by their rules our
rules and by law every
every bill has to be heard within our
body unless it doesn't get to us it
came out of there out of that uh body
was not passed okay so this is
this is a separate okay so it's
understanding this like
the second bill the same thing that's
what it is
it's a second bill just like we've had
second bills on numerous
uh legislation even this year that are
on the house side
and the senate side okay play god
okay thank you okay so we're going to
open up now the hearing for
oh you skipped me out we're not supposed
to start the 9 30 i'm just reminded i'm
trying to get out of here today so we're
going to hang loose here
okay
yeah to answer your question for the
snow before
we had uh eight inches of snow last year
yesterday
whoa but this year this year we're 30
inches down
oh yeah we're three inches down from our
average over here so
the wells are going to be tough and
stuff i mean the river's already open
next to me i should use it i stopped for
another two or three weeks
so yeah we didn't we didn't get much
was that bad for skiing no skiing and
skiing they did fine
yeah you know a little late a little
late starting but they did fine
they still get some good some high
elevation stuff is still good yeah yeah
but pretty much everything's closed down
now they're not making obviously anymore
but yeah it was just it was amazing uh
you know look outside we still i mean
we're still snow covered around my house
i got a good eight or ten inches all the
way around the house oh
but oh but we're not getting you know
you know
i'll ship you some if you need it no no
no no yeah but 38 30
nothing says drought more than
no snowpack oh my goodness yeah
the point driven wells they're gonna be
suffering again
yep like i said like i said the river is
wide open already so then that never
not gonna be good do you have a well sue
in
in bedford no i have the
beauty of lake massabesic coming right
to my home
yeah we have poland springs but
i don't have a welcome in here
yeah i
don't see we're going to go ahead now
and open up
sb 20 this is an app relative to one
year's certificate spell's ability to
teach
and what i'm going to do i've been asked
by senator khan to
introduce this bill and then i'm going
to turn it over to
mr appleby at the department of
education to explain that
so with that i my name is rick flatt
i'm from naval new hampshire
i'm here today to introduce sb
20 this is a bill relative to one year
certificates availability to teach
and we've had many a discussion on the
cte advisory uh council commission
regarding this and there is need for
many of these retired folks that have
been working 30
35 years in industry who may not have
a uh a certificate or a degree
and a bachelor's degree but they have
all the technician type certificates
and um it is the opinion of the advisory
council that we
we move forward with allowing these
people to have
a one-year certificate to allow them to
teach in the various career technical
education centers
um with that uh if the committee doesn't
have any objections i'd like to have
uh mr appleby steve appleby
um uh take it from there
yep go ahead mr appleby welcome to
education
good morning and uh thank you
representatives and mr chair
of the record steve appleby division
director at the new hampshire department
of education
uh the purpose of this bill is to line
up the requirements
in the one-year certificate of
eligibility with
what's already in statute and rule for a
full license
currently a cte teacher is not required
to have a bachelor's degree for example
a welding
teacher or a mechanic teacher auto
mechanic teacher
they are required to have typically
industry recognized
certifications but not a bachelor's
degree and
the one-year certificate of eligibility
as it currently
is the law prohibits districts
from using this
kind of emergency situation certificate
to fill
a position by changing
the law to drop the bachelor's
requirement just for the cte specialty
area teachers
this would allow districts to build
you know their gaps or their needs for
representative woodcock has his hand
released representative
thank you chairman lad i missed out with
you thank you thank you for taking my
question just
for my own edification if i may so
you're talking about
uh cte bringing in a welding instructor
uh for example uh no academic
training perfectly fine um has the
skills do that
is there and this is a one-year one-year
piece
uh i have two questions what happens
after one year
and two is there any point in time where
these folks have to take
any uh teacher uh student skills in
terms of uh
technology and those things and how to
use
that type of program with students
teacher training basically yeah uh thank
you for the question representative
uh great questions so um is the first
the first question as i understand it
was what happens after the one year
yes sir yep and um this one-year
eligibility is a one-time per person
only certificate so if john or sally
smith
receives one of these and takes a
position in a district
once the year is up they are no longer
eligible
to teach unless they have pursued and
gain
full certification of full license or in
the intern license process
so uh if they don't do that they're out
of a job
okay and then they very far
representative vlad
yes you have two questions thank you so
the
second start they may take one of the
alternative tracks to get certified
after that
yes and in fact very often they begin
that process while working in the one
year
time period okay thank you so much for
clarifying that for me i appreciate it
thank you representative thank you um
i cannot see any other androids
that correct no other questions for
thanks very much mr chair and uh and
thanks very much
mr appleby for um for testifying this
morning
um i i don't have the exact terminology
in front of me but i know we've we've
referenced it
um other places and it was um it was
kind of a big deal
uh two years ago when the department of
education brought forward a new
um standard of and and i
i'm i'm just trying to whether it was
standard of ethics a code of conduct
code of conduct thank you and and i was
wondering if
um if that code of conduct will apply to
um
to these teachers thank you
representative another great question
yes
um the code of conduct code of ethics do
apply to these individuals
thank you see no further
questions and uh there is no one else
signed up to testify
uh i will close the hearing
on sb 20
and i see that uh
there were ten signed in in support
thank you very much uh i am going to go
into an executive session on this bill
and i'm going to hand the gavel over to
represent cordelia so i can make a
motion
uh thank you yeah i would have followed
you for an emotion
emotion or emotional emotion okay thank
you very much
[Music]
the advisory group has worked on this
with dle and with all the various
folks that are on that commission
we recognize that any individual who
comes on
that receives a one year or a five year
certificate
uh must comply with the code of conduct
as a representative passed that has
required
anybody to have certification even paris
which had
uh certification um further um
been talking to the directors of the cte
centers they recognize the value of this
uh when they're getting down to having
to conduct courses
uh they have folks that in the past that
have not got the alternative road
completed
and are prepared based upon their
understandings and yes uh when we asked
what about the methods of how to teach
and how to communicate properly
uh mr rothenberger over at concord high
school
who's the director of that center and
again that's my job to
ensure that i'm supervising and ensuring
that the instructions proper in the
classroom
which is exactly right so i'd like to
really encourage us to
move this bill on it is a bipartisan
bill
one of which is needed in our career
technical education centers
mr speaker mr chairman representative
shaw will be
offering comments no uh i agree and i
think it's
needed thank you thank you
just a quick comment i i haven't had the
opportunity to work in two vocational
schools
plus do my internship there for my
master's and be a principal of one
uh this is a terrific piece and and i
i support it wholeheartedly and it will
help public school
uh and cte bringing qualified staff
thank you thank you
so uh president john
uh okay
this is octopass on senate bill
20. representative cordelli
yeah representative boehm yes
representative allard
yes representative yes
representative moffett yes
representative
hobson yes representative andres
yes representative ford yes
president leon yes representative
yes senator miller
yes representative luna
yes representative shaw yes
representative cornell yes
yes yes
honey zero any objections to consent
is that okay with everybody
representative lad i'm sorry
um any any objections to consent
no no okay
thank you okay thank you to everybody
i i know our tps will really appreciate
this bill and it will really
assist uh our getting kids on the right
pathways for these technologies
necessary for today's careers
uh with that uh we had scheduled i
believe
was there a half hour for this one as
well no so we started to attend
so we have uh 15 minutes here
uh once again we're gonna have to wait
before we introduce the next bill the
next bill is
sb24 um dealing with rooster academy
so we were up 15 minute loss again
um
[Music]
hmm
can you guys hear us yes i can
i i wonder if that if the guys in the
room can hear us they're not
we can't hear them i don't know if they
know that or not
yeah have you done a great job this
session uh
coordinating all this stuff for somebody
who's not done it before it's uh
get you everywhere well it's it's it's
not easy to do and
you've done a very nice job thank you oh
thank you
okay this is our second try we unmuted
the machine here
and pop back on it was muted so i hope
everybody can hear us now we're random
head with uh senate bill 24 and this is
relative to
brewster academy charter and we have
represented uh john mcdonald
president uh he is one of the sponsors
that are going to interview
john good morning mr chairman
and members of the house education
committee my name is representative john
k mcdonald and i represent cal district
six
which is the community of uh wolfeboro
unfortunately senator bradley is tied up
with a southern obligation
and asked me to introduce this bill to
you today
uh senator bradley will also like to ask
me to pass on
his continued support of this
legislation uh sb 24 came over from the
senate
uh with a unanimous ought to pass in
committee of uh 5-0
and a vote of 23-1 uh in the in this
session
um this bill was filed last year in 2020
but was one of the bills that was
incorporated into a large anonymous bill
hb1234 and did not survive the whole
legislative process uh
due to covert what this bill simply does
it amends the childhood booster academy
so they can make changes to the chatter
in accordance with provisions of rsa 292
colon 7.
it also increases the membership of
booster academy's board of trustees
at the present time booster academy must
come before the legislature
to make any changes to the charter and
that seems kind of unreasonable uh
where we are in our you know uh system
of uh
government uh there's gonna be a uh
individual christie
karen who is the associate head of our
school
of worcester academy and she should be
able to explain to you the
particular need and requirement the
booster has for this legislation to be
passed
uh thank you thank you very much rex and
mcdonald are there any questions for
representative mcdonald
not seeing any hands up uh thank you
thank you mr chairman you're you're
welcome
uh is representative there available
is he here uh yes i did yep he's already
been promoted go ahead
uh thank you mr chairman for letting me
speak and thank you uh to the committee
for letting me speak today i just wanted
to voice my support for
sb 24 which would amend um it would
allow brewster academy to amend their
own charter and increase the number of
trustees they have on their board
from 25 to 30. uh this is a very
important issue in our community so then
brewster academy won't always have to
constantly
appeal to the house education committee
in the general court to be able to make
uh simple amendments to their charter
they would be able to demand their
charter like a number of other private
schools are around the state
and um you know throughout the general
court's uh history over the last you
know
few decades we've allowed uh private
organizations and private schools people
to amend their own charters or granted
to them
from the state and so having this kind
of autonomy makes so they're more
responsive to
their workers their staff and uh our
overall community here in wolfeboro so
i encourage the uh committee to vote
ought to pass
on this legislation thank you
thank you very much representative are
awesome thank you you're welcome thank
you
uh rexella hopps and dewey of others in
the queue
uh yes we do have christy karen um
as representative mcdonald
mentioned them trying if chris
is there available perhaps you could
give us a little bit more
understanding of why we have pulled from
25 to
christy
sorry about that i was muted good
morning everyone um thank you so much
again it's this is christy karen i'm the
associate head of school at brewster
uh i'd just like to thank senator
bradley for bringing this legislation
forward
to representative mcdonald for his
support throughout the process
and also to representative des for for
supporting
with his comments this morning thank you
all so much for your time today
brewster academy celebrated its
bicentennial anniversary last year
our original charter was granted by the
new hampshire general court
on june 20th 1820. today brewster serves
350 students from roughly 23 states and
21 countries
80 percent of our students are boarding
students and 20 percent
are day students from the local area
over one-third of our students receive
financial aid support in order to attend
the academy
brewster's mission is to prepare diverse
thinkers for lives of purpose
we're proud to serve a truly diverse
population by every definition of the
word
ethnically socioeconomically and
cognitively
brewster has an exceptional board of
trustees it's a forward-thinking group
including two current parents ten former
parents
four alumni two grandparents and four
friends of the school
our trustees have really impressive
backgrounds they're recognized leaders
in their fields
and they all actively contribute their
expertise in service to brewster
so while the work of the board has been
outstanding there are
some composition issues that we're
hoping to address with this bill
first brewster would like to expand the
size of the board from 25 to 30 members
as we continue to expand our range of
programs
including some new global programs we'd
like to further add to the range of
skill sets on our board
we have run up against the 25 member
threshold in the past
and we want to ensure that we don't have
to turn away any potential trustees who
can contribute to our mission and our
vision
we'd also like to eliminate the position
held by a representative of the alumni
association
the alumni association it's is no longer
active in a formal traditional sense
uh but we do have four alumni on our
board currently and
and we will continue to actively seek
alumni who represent a range of
viewpoints and graduation years and
finally we are requesting that the
legislature
grant permission for brewster's board of
trustees to manage future amendments to
its charter
rather than approach the legislature
every time that a change is needed
the academy would like to take the same
approach that was taken by dartmouth
college
in 2003 and by pinkerton academy in 2011
in hopes of you know avoiding using your
valuable time
for amendments such as board size and
composition in the future
so thank you again to senator bradley
for bringing this bill forward
to representatives mcdonald and to chase
for their support and to you all for
your time this morning
thank you very much uh miss karen are
there questions
looks like everybody's got it thank you
very much nope we have rep leon
yes uh thank you mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my question
uh my question is um in regards to
referencing the pinkerton issue
do you take any public funds um do you
have anybody who is uh sending town to
brewster academy or is this all just
privately paid
um we do have local students attending
brewster academy
um we did apply
uh in the local ppp funding
um this year as other private schools in
our region
did and we do accept
title 2a funding for faculty
professional development
that's what i'm aware of there may be
other pieces i'm just not aware of
thank you thank you thank you
are there further questions
thank you very much do we have anybody
else
in the queue represent hobson not that i
can see
thank you so
we have a summary of the folks who
signed in on that bill
yep so we have three that signed in in
support
to oppose pose zero neutral
and testifying i guess we could say four
um jet senator bradley signed up to
speak
thank you very much so with that i'm
going to close the
uh sb 24 uh bill relative to booster
academy
charter uh we have about six or seven
minutes left here
um i i think what i'll do is just open
up
and go into an executive session for
this bill
and recognize uh representative for a
motion
is there a further discussion from
representative not seeing
there a further discussion from members
of the committee
russia and thank you mr chair
i just wanted to make sure that uh since
there's not
there's not a issue of school districts
that are sending a huge chunk of
students to brewster academy is that
correct
um and if that's the case i don't have
any any problems i'm just uh
in dairy we have some issues with
transparency so that was just my
question if uh if there might be an
issue
up there um if not i have no problem
amending the truth
they do have public schools contracts
with
uh various schools that came with me
so um basically
simply that we're looking to allow the
people at blue stream to cat booster
academy to
make those changes rather than have to
come to this particular
you know board or to the legislature for
all your occurrences of change to their
character
okay thank you it sounds like there's
more transparency there than in derry so
i'm in favor thank you
in the next town i know
that uh brewster academy is very
involved in the community
and certainly a good neighbor
within town of wolverhampton
thank you uh not seeing any
on senate bill 24.
yes representative yes
senator moffat yes representative hobson
yes representative andres yes
yes representative leon
yes representative saudi yes
senator miller yes representative
yes president ellison yes
representative mullen yes representative
yes i said it would cop yes
yes
instead okay with everyone it looks like
everybody
so with that i'm closing the executive
session on
sb 24 our next session will start
at 9 or 10 excuse me 10
20 and that will be uh sb
thank you so we have a few moments here
that's my message to internet tennessee
[Music]
do you like me to mute the room
okay i'd like to go ahead and open up
the hearing
okay it looks like folks can hear us now
i i'd like to go ahead and introduce uh
our discuss senate bill 135
this is an act relative to the
and the bill is going to be presented by
senator aaron hennessey
welcome erin good morning everybody
i am erin hennessey i am center for
district one and that covers thornton
all the way through pittsburgh
i'm here to introduce senate bill 135
and what this bill does is fix some
unforeseen challenges that our schools
have had with
as a result of the pandemic i'm sure
you've all heard from your
your uh superintendents that they are
concerned with the funding formula for
next year because of drops in their
average daily membership that they've
seen
in addition they've had a difficult time
getting back free and reduced lunch
forms from parents or guardians
and both of these have an impact on next
year's school funding
so what this bill does is says if a
school for some reason
didn't see a drop in average daily
membership and was able to get back
their school forms
and will and the calculation for the
funding
is that they'll get more than this year
next year they'll get that
but if for some reason they've seen a
drop uh in
in their attendance because of kovid and
that they they
have not received back theirs their free
and reduced lunch forms
they will receive the higher of the
calculation for next year
or the funding that they've received
this year
uh it has a fiscal impact of
approximately 45 million dollars
and as we are looking at the federal
requirements coming into the state
for the uh funding that the um
the approximately one billion dollars
new hampshire is going to receive but
also
extra funds that are going directly to
our schools
some of the requirements are we are
requiring a maintenance of effort
that the state must fund the 22 23
school
school years proportional to those the
spending that they've done
2017 through 2019 so this bill is very
important in that we
need to increase the school funding for
next year
to be proportional to what we've done in
prior years
i'm happy to take questions otherwise
someone from the department of education
can answer all your difficult questions
thank you very much senator hennessey
represent luna thank you very much mr
chair and thank you very much senator
hennessey for joining us this morning
and for uh for introducing uh
senate bill 135. um i i certainly i
certainly support the um
uh what your uh what what the intention
is um
on this but my my the question i have
is i wonder if you could sort of break
down
the um the 45 million dollar price tag
in terms of
the um the adma factor
and uh is there a um a cost
index factor um uh with this as well
a cost index factor do you mean um the
inflationary factor that usually goes
into the funding formula
no this is yeah well this is um
this is the formula the state uses
for next year using this um
last year's student numbers so if the
the for the cost the inflationary factor
is in the formula
then yes it stays in there okay thank
you
i'm not seeing anything get back to your
finance
oh i'm in senate session right now thank
you very much okay thank you very much
okay
who is next repression uh
next we had leslie want but i do not see
her in the queue um
scott marion let's see if
oh um caitlyn davis is here
from the what's your department
okay miss davis i've uh promoted you
and you're a statement i can thank you
could you also bring in mark maganello
there you are okay so i'm not sure if
mark has actually testified in front of
this committee before
um he's been working with finance quite
a bit so just a reminder for those of
you who
have not met mark mark works over here
at the department of education now
he did work at the lba we're very lucky
to have him here now at the department
but that's why he looks familiar
i mean he's helping us in the office of
school finance
so he is going to kind of help
answer any questions that the committee
may have
about this bill one thing i actually do
want to bring up
before i take any questions is the
department has
asked for an amendment to this bill we
had sort of an
aha in the middle of the night moment
about
assessments um and we realized that this
bill references the assessment
of the previous year in 1920 like all of
the
rest of the data however there was not
an assessment that was implemented
in 1920 that has comprehensive
assessment results to be used for the
purpose of third grade reading and
adequacy
so we would in fact actually to have an
accurate
number need to refer back to the 18 and
19 assessment data
so we did ask for that amendment we
realized it yesterday and we sent it
over to representative vlad i'm not sure
if you were able to
get that figured out or not but that was
just something that we realized so
um given that um we'll take any
questions i think mark is going to
kind of try to feel them and we'll see
how it goes uh thank you very much
you did mention 1920 and i don't think
too many of us around in 1920 you're
talking 2020 right
uh yes sorry fiscal year school year
2019 and
20. like 20 19 20 20.
okay i got there um seeing that you
you're is mark going to stay with us
throughout this
yes what what i plan on doing here is
having uh folks that would like to speak
to
the bill as was introduced by aaron
hennessey
uh but we have three three amendments
here
and i'd like to have mark stay with us
or you're even yourself campbell you may
be boxing back and forth for finance
but um uh i know one of those uh mark
that you spoke to and mark explained
that
the 2018-19 data compared to the 2021
so we can get into that but also we will
be documenting
all three of those without having to put
them on the floor for action it's going
to be a discussion oriented
session so caitlyn
do you have any anything else offers on
the bills it was introduced or if you
spoke to the one amendment that
your you all are involved with uh are
you going to speak for that are you
going to let
mark do that when we get to it yep so
i'm going to let mark take over i'm i
actually
am in another meeting right now so i'm
going to jump back over to the other one
and
mark i think has got it completely
handled so um i'm in the office across
the hall from him if he he has anything
that actually comes up so
but i think he's going to know all of
the answers okay
so thank you very much uh caitlyn and um
we'll work with mark on the rest of this
uh you have a good time in finance
thank you for the subject so
have a good one okay uh we're gonna go
on
and take some testimony from others who
are waiting in the queue
and then we're gonna get into these
amendments
following hearing from other folks so
who is next on the doc
um next we have jeff nick lynch
i have promoted him it'll just take a
second
uh good morning can everyone hear me yes
wonderful thank you so much uh chairman
lad representative milor members of the
committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify on senate bill five this morning
for the record my name is jeff micklinch
and i'm the project director
after school funding fairness project
the aim of senate bill 135 is clear as
it seeks to protect against
the covet 19 pandemic's possible impact
on school finances
the need for the bills enactment is
urgent as communities across new
hampshire
continue to weigh difficult budgetary
decisions for the coming year
given the long-standing problems that
have plagued new hampshire's school
funding system
as well as the new challenges students
families and schools now face
i urge the committee to strengthen
senate bill 135
and to recommend it as ought to pass
once amended similarly
i urge the house as a whole to act on
the bill as quickly as possible
and barring any timely action by the
house on this measure
as a separate piece of legislation i
would ask you and your colleagues to
incorporate its provisions
along with other changes in the law
designed to address an anticipated 90
million
shortfall in education aid into the
house's version
of the fiscal 2223 budget
you know this committee is obviously
well familiar with the fact that
two of the key determinants of the
amount of state education aid
are the number of students community
service generally as well as the
number of low-income students in that
community
critically the vast majority of
districts in new hampshire have seen
those numbers decline
as a result of the pandemic just to put
specific numbers to it
the department of education's november
15th estimates
suggest that uh attendance will decline
by about four percent
um over the past year uh while certainly
the long-term trend has been towards
declining enrollments
a four percent drop is particularly
steep uh those estimates also point to a
roughly 24
decrease in the count of free and
reduced price lunch students
uh those figures obviously fluctuate
from year to year
but during times of economic hardship
like that like those engendered by the
pandemic
you'd expect those numbers to rise not
fall and those numbers are
ultimately going to rebound as the
pandemic wanes
and as schools resume in-person classes
uh in the coming year
um to an even greater extent than they
do already
but because of as you know the time lag
in the formula
barring necessary changes in law those
temporary lower student counts
will be used to decide the amount of
state aid districts receive in 2122
as senator hennessey discussed senate
bill 135 recognizes
that the accounts we're seeing now
aren't likely to reflect the situation
schools will face this fall and comes up
with an alternative using the higher of
um districts or towns uh adma
over the past two years to calculate the
state education aid
and so certainly while passage of this
bill is vital
the bill could be made strong or small
in order to preserve the progress that
the legislature made in the current
budget
in bolstering state education aid and
targeting it to those cities and towns
most in need
the budget agreement reached in the fall
of 2019 added two elements to new
hampshire's funding formula for fiscal
additional aid designed to assist cities
and towns with higher
of low-income students and fiscal
capacity disparity aid
which is designed to help municipalities
with comparatively low property values
given that the inequities that these two
types of aid were designed to address
are going to be just as severe in the
coming biennium
as they are in the current one i would
ask the committee to amend senate bill
to extend these two forms of aid for
now certainly passage of senate bill 135
in its present form or an amended form
would reduce the need for the potential
scale of changes like
um spending reductions in local schools
or higher property tax increases
and obviously municipalities are already
grappling um
with those decisions many have made
those decisions but they do have the
authority under current law
under rsa 197 3a
to revisit those decisions should
additional state education aid become
available
uh so i would just ask you know and
point out that it's imperative
that the legislature send a clear signal
to all municipalities as quickly as
possible
so that they can ready themselves for
these meetings and reconsider these
decisions
before the school uh year gets underway
so in conclusion
the kobet 19 pandemic has tragically
taken the lives of more than a thousand
granite staters
disrupted the new hampshire economy and
up ended our daily lives in
ways large and small we shouldn't allow
it to continue to have adverse
consequences for our schools
and the children and families they serve
so once again i urge the committee to
strengthen senate bill 135
to recommend it as optipass and to do so
as expeditiously as possible
look forward to working with all of you
to try to address these pressing issues
and i'd be happy to try to answer any
questions you might have thank you
questions
uh i i have one question and i'll just
open it up to the committee
could you please go into a little bit
our attendance is down four percent but
the 24
decrease in freedom redundancy reduced
numbers could you
explain that a little bit more please
yeah so um in some ways the
that reduction is a good thing and by
which i mean
the reason that that 24 reduction is
happening
is that the federal government in
response to the pandemic
took steps to make it easier for
families to obtain needed food
assistance
they waive the requirement that people
complete the food work that excuse me
the paperwork necessary
to receive food assistance and are in
essence providing free lunches to
everyone who may want it
however the downside of that is that
that paperwork
was is what the state uses to arrive at
its counts for free and reduced price
lunch students
and those counts in turn are
incorporated into the adequacy aid
formula
so that people aren't filling out that
paperwork
and districts have gone in some lengths
to try to get them to do so
they're not going to show up in those
counts but once the federal government
ends this program
people are still going to be in need and
they're going to begin completing that
paperwork once again
so you'll see a very rapid uptick in
those counts
but because of the lag in the formula um
you know those kids will still be there
and need to be served
but will have suppressed aid as a result
of this change
yeah i have one one follow-up to what
you just
spoke to um so schools that have the
freedom to use they'll have frankly
these programs within it
are they providing the free do this
program to all students
at low-cost students uh are they doing
any paperwork during this pandemic
uh i would defer to uh staff from the
department of education about the
delivery
and the paperwork i do know you know
based on prior testimony and other
hearings
that there have been some communities
that have you know gone to great lengths
to try to get
this paperwork completed um and there
are others that just simply done with
the capacity so there may be varying
efforts
but i think even in places where they
have tried to make the effort
that the take-up is still relatively you
know the
completion rate is still relatively low
thank you
are there questions for mr mcclinch
representative
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much uh mr mick lynch for
joining us this morning
i was wondering if you could um um talk
with us a little bit about the
connection between
um concentrations of
students and families with in lower
socioeconomic
with lower socioeconomic means and the
sort of expected costs that a school
district
would uh would incur for uh for
educating its students
absolutely so um you know there is a
very direct connection
in that uh lower income students tend to
have uh
greater needs and therefore uh schools
need greater resources to address them
the current formula
um you know recognizes that in in
installing the free and reduced price
launch accounts in there
um you know i will say that i touched
upon sort of existing inequities
as it relates to these issues the
commission to study school funding as
you well know uh looked at these issues
at some length over the past
year and the conclusion that they
arrived at is that um
you know the current system is
inequitable from both a student and
taxpayer perspective and just to quote
their report
the districts serving the highest
proportion of students who are
economically disadvantaged spend less on
average
compared with districts serving the
fewest that students moreover districts
with the least property wealth per
student imposed the highest local
education tax rates
to be able to fund their children's
education so given that there's
certainly a need to continue with
additional aid and fiscal capacity
disparity aid until
longer term reforms are put in place
and then a follow up on that mr chair
yeah thank you very much and um
and and thanks again for for for
answering that
i was wondering if you could also sort
of extend that analysis
towards um towards really the the the
student equity
um you know element of um of
how well these students in you know that
come from
higher concentrations of of uh or
i should say student students aware let
me say it another way
districts where there are higher
concentrations of of
low-income families and how that
reflects upon
student performance yeah i think there's
a direct
relationship between those two and again
i'd be happy to sort of provide
um reference to the commission's uh
study report i don't have it at hand
here
but i looked at that very question i
believe and you know established
or sort of underscored the fact that
the student the districts that tend to
spend less tend to have students who are
having trouble performing even though
there is that greater need
thank you further
questions uh for uh
mr mcclinch i might add
that in follow-up to the question you
just asked absolutely
we know with those communities that have
a property level
a property valuation of 660 000
or less we have 85 percent of the
students in those districts
are functioning and quartile one or two
of the proficiency tests
where we have then 15
in three and four that's above the
bottom
so there's a direct relationship between
you know the device property valuation
which is also associated often times
with poverty
um pre-reduced counts there is a real
good correlation here between
already any other questions for mr mc
lynch
thank you very much john thank you
sorry next we have leslie want and i've
i hope she'll be here in a minute i i am
here hello
oh good okay welcome to education
oh thanks thank you so much it was
was not easy to find not easy to find
this link this morning for some reason
but anyway you know that i believe
we're having a hard time hearing here in
that video
okay um maybe if i just put my mouth a
little closer does that help at all
it's a little bit better okay um i
wanted to let you
know too that dr goldhart i believe it
is also in
and would like to speak at some point he
he's our superintendent here in
manchester
but i'm the vice chair here in the at
the manchester city school district
and um we are strongly in support of
bill 135
um our district will lose a great deal
of money
if we use the attendance numbers from
this year as opposed to using them from
one of the previous two years
so we are strongly in support of this we
stand too right now
with the attic the reduction adequacy
aid
we're having fewer students standalones
1.2 million dollars here in manchester
and as you all know in manchester we
have some of the neediest students
in the state with our high numbers of
pre-reduced lunch students and high
numbers of students that are
in the el population we also stand to
lose
four million dollars in uh reduced aid
from our pre-reduced lunch so that's
also something we're hoping the senate
will consider
um fixing for next year but i would also
ask
if possible if you can uh promote dr
goldhart to speak um
i'm sure you'd be interested in hearing
what he had to say okay yes he's on my
list i can
i can promote him if that's okay uh
representative ladd
yes okay thank you very much you're
welcome
okay good morning mr goldhard
thank you for having me i just want to
reiterate as the superintendent of our
largest school district the positive
impact this bill would have for us
we have a great number of students who
do qualify
for free reduced lunch but due to the
current situation where
everybody is pretty much qualified
we have not been able to get those
applications back
but we know the students are still here
and our enrollment has dropped this year
however most of that enrollment drop was
in kindergarten in first grade
and we think many of these students will
return next year
when we're back to it we hope a more
normal year
and i like this bill because it helps
districts like
us be held harmless and as vice chair
want had shared
we have very high needs students
and these funds make a dramatic impact
because we know
title one funds will be cut for us
because of
the free reduced lunch numbers and so
this will help us
a lot and i appreciate this bill
and the the effort that has been put
into it to help districts like ours
so that we can serve our students in our
be in the best way possible so we
strongly support it
thank you thank you very much uh john uh
are there questions for the
yes i have a question um can you
i wish i could explain where all of them
have gone
uh the problem is is with kindergarten
we don't know where they were to start
with
but when we look at the numbers that had
the biggest
drop where our normal numbers for
kindergarten were
much lower than they've been every year
and i know we didn't have a
that big of a drop in births that year
so i think there was a lot of concern
about having kids in school because of
covert now i do know our enrollment is
dropping just like the whole state
that is true but it is not
this the high number that we've had this
year
[Music]
thank you you're welcome further
questions
thanks for very much mr chair and uh
thanks very much um
uh dr goldhart for joining us this
morning it's great to see you again
um i hadn't even connected the um
you know the the fact of
of a reduction in free and reduced price
lunch
and uh receipt of federal title 1 funds
and i was wondering if you could sort of
talk a little bit more about that
how that affects manchester and and
maybe
and i know it's hard to sort of
calculate but but
how how that could be projected as a as
a statewide loss in
federal dollars to support public
education yeah i don't have the exact
figures for me the title one but it is
dramatic for us because it's based upon
free reduced lunch and because we don't
have
those total numbers like we've had
before our title 1 funds are going to
drop by at least 40 or 50 percent or
more
this next year for us and my guess is
other districts will have
dramatic losses as well because the free
reduced lunch numbers
are not the same and this will hurt us
a lot and so what you're doing is going
to help us dramatically and then we hope
by the next year
when we can get those free reduced
numbers where they
should be then the title one funds will
come back but yes on the federal side
there will be a drop
follow up on that mr chair yeah and and
if you could just sort of refresh
refresh my memory how how districts use
title 1 funds
they're used in multiple ways we use
them for additional
instructors we use them for additional
materials
we use them for additional professional
learning for schools that are title one
we use them for additional
other supports but the most the most of
the cost is in additional instruction
and additional material
thank you you're welcome uh
uh uh superintendent i i have a question
of you
um rick william um
yeah i've been an administrator and i
know how title one runs are so important
to a school district especially for
healthy remedial situations
um can you tell me one
i asked this question of another
individual regarding the
free and reduced uh meal applications
and i know of some districts that just
have provided free meals to everybody
you've indicated you're down a
significant percentage here
um did you get any applications back or
if you tried to get applications
and um it's i know there's a real
issue uh i just like know whether you
were
we still were probably required to get
these
applications out and or were you
given the latitude by the uh by the
state
or the feds that uh that you didn't have
to do so
the latitude was continued for the rest
of the year to provide it for all
but we've continued to reach out to get
applications we're not stopping
uh the problem has been we're not
getting them back even though we've
tried in multiple methods
and we're getting people to take
advantage of the lunches
but we know they qualify but we need the
paperwork
and we're we're still trying
representative thank you mr chair i'm
not sure whether this question
is to dr goldhart or to our
representative from the department
but this uh issue of um
knowing where these students are and
free and reduced lunch is not just
within this state
the federal government may have some
understanding or feedback of this
problem has there been
any uh note from the federal government
regarding
latitude in dealing with this topic
since it's obviously all over the
country not just in this state
i know our board sent a letter to our
congressional delegation
on this very issue and then my national
association the national association for
superintendents has been lobbying as
well at the federal level
because it is a national issue where all
districts across the country
are going to have title 1 reductions
this year because of this exact problem
mark have you heard anything from the
feds on this
yeah uh thank you for the question uh
just recently i think like a week or two
ago the feds announced
um for the title programs within the
department of education we can use
the best available fnr data so they gave
us flexibility to fix this problem on
the federal funding side for schools
but um you're right it's it is a
national issue um
sp 30 sb 135 seeks to fix it for the
the state issue as far as how it's
impacting adequacy but the federal
issue for the title programs have been
has been resolved at this moment
i'd like to follow that question up that
representative had
i think this is a serious issue for all
public schools throughout the country i
have
four grandchildren across the river in
vermont and
they have not had to pay for meals this
year they've been provided by the school
district
all kids are receiving it over there uh
so
how's that going to impact their title
one month
is it just that the feds are going to
allow us to go back to like
1819 of those uh that that year or 1920
where which one we have to go to so my
understanding is they've given
flexibility so uh best available data so
the best available data
the the 2019 2020 data should be pretty
good
um it depends on how vermont manages
their data systems
but um vermont should have the same
flexibility that new hampshire has as
far as
the federal program
thank you are there further questions
for the superintendent from manchester
united you might want to hang with us in
case we have more questions
uh rexella hopson who's next in
okay oh well actually uh rep luno signed
up to speak and i didn't know if you
want to take this opportunity replino
so i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna defer to when
rick wants to when the chair wants to
introduce amendments
but um but i do see um dr kaskadin
um is uh has her hand up okay
oh is that is that the um iran
okay i wasn't sure who that was
she's there she is okay welcome to
education
good morning can you hear me okay well
first of all thank you uh committee
members
i am dr corrine cascade and i'm a 45
year educator with 32 years served as a
school principal and a school
superintendent
uh so i'm very familiar with school
budgets uh
primarily for the city of berlin i urge
you to support
senate bill 135 along with its
uh proposed amendments that you will
soon hear 10 12 and 10
20. currently we have
crippling school budgets in the north
country school districts namely berlin
groveton colebrook white mountain and
others
it is critical for school operations to
have the fiscal disparity aid
and as well as additional aid for free
and reduced
accounts in the next biennium berlin has
closed three buildings in my tenure
due in part to enrollment and in part to
financial capital
so a couple of years back the berlin
school board initiated a solve education
funding campaign
because we're in such dire straits and
yet that's
hasn't been really seen by the
legislature
and the reason for that is you need to
understand that the city of berlin has
about
32 to 35 percent of taxable property
in the city of berlin which leaves an
estimated 65 percent of the city of
berlin is tax-exempt
because of prisons federal and state
buildings
so you really can't raise the revenue i
currently pay
39.52 cents per thousand
um in 2019 the district closed the last
elementary school
and had to eliminate a korean technical
education administrator
position because we just did not raise
the funding
how can students have equitable
opportunities when there's no capacity
to grow
or adapt to the new hampshire workforce
with our students
please take a close look at the local
communities
and their capacity to raise local
property taxes
based on the property within that
community
by not approving or amending senate bill
and the amendments i believe you're
declaring it's okay for inequitable
public schools
and if you know me um i've fought for
this equity
um for quite a few years now and it
really gets discouraging
and in the meantime while people are
waiting and studying this
issue um things become worse and worse
um i had the pleasure of serving on the
school funding commission
which uh really has data and research
that should be invaluable to the state
legislators
on how to make our public schools
equitable
i'd like to thank senator hennessey for
representing district one
and thank you house members for taking a
few minutes to listen to me i just
missed the
sign up at eight o'clock by about five
minutes so thank you representative luna
for letting me in
i appreciate it thank you very much
uh are there questions for the
i don't serve as a superintendent of
berlin anymore oh you're not
no i finished in littleton last year oh
littleton
thanks very much mr chair and thank you
very much dr caskadin for um
for your time this morning i hope you'll
be able to hang on with us as we uh
go through the amendments um as well but
um
but speaking about just the the
underlying bill
senate bill 135 does does that bring us
back to
fy21 funding the current school year
with the
with the um uh with the equitable grants
that
were put into the the last state budget
or or is that is this more of a baseline
to fy19 fyi more like fy20
yeah i mean i may have not got dr
cascadin
can you can you hear me yes
all right so so i have a question for
you um
with with regards to the the bill
and um as it as it stands right now
um my understanding based on your your
testimony
is that without the amendments this
doesn't
make school districts whole to the
current
um state funding that this really only
brings
brings you know makes makes them whole
to sort of like funding from two years
ago by
by at least looking at um
at at uh pre-pandemic uh enrollment
levels
but it it does not have the um the
the two equitable grants that does not
include the two up
equitable grants i think you were
referring to for
um for um low property valuation
and for um for student equity with
through free and reduced price lunch
uh yes that is correct because you got
to understand i mean two years ago
the cost of salaries materials
and programs was you know
two years ago and so now you're talking
moving forward
without the additional aid to increase
for cost increases of expenses you've
got to lay off staff to be able to make
up the difference to operate
less than you did two years ago because
the funding has not kept up with the
cost
i don't know if that answers your
question
yeah thank you karine yeah further
president thompson who is next in the
queue
we have my gary crew there yes we do uh
carl ladd was scheduled to speak and
he's not here
um let's see if mr frew
good morning mr frew good morning
thank you representative hobson for
letting me in the house
and thank you chairman ladd
and members of the committee for um
entertaining what will be very short
testimony today um
as karine and john and
illustrated in their testimony by the
way my name is jerry fruit i'm the
associate executive director of
the new hampshire school administrators
association and
we do appreciate fully appreciate
senator hennessey
and representative luno listening to our
concerns
uh that have been pretty eloquently put
forth by
uh jeff mc lynch and reiterated uh with
the
testimony of john and corrine um
this disparity aid and um
the holding harmless provision due to
the loss of funds
by free and reduced lunch is so critical
to our most struggling communities and
we really support
sb 135 as the proposed amendments
the most struggling communities and most
struggling students are the ones who
will benefit
the most from a positive action on this
legislation and so uh we encourage its
support
and i believe that
there'll be plenty of information shared
moving forward regarding to
specific impacts of specific communities
but
this loss of revenue for school
districts is dramatic in
those communities that need it most and
so
again we appreciate the sponsors support
and would really appreciate the support
of this committee
in moving the amended piece of
legislation forward
thank you are there questions for mr
fruit
jerry i have one question for you uh
last year
or i was last year of the year before
that
the national school boards association
put out an
advisory to school regarding
the use of pre-reduced additional aid
and the physical capacity disparity
exchange known as
a one-time deal and
to invest your knowledge have most
districts
use that this money for one-time
issues or have they had to use this
money for
long-term you long-term contract or
other
lease type issues thank you for the
question mr chairman
without having specific knowledge i
would generally say
that districts have used that one-time
money in a one-time
fashion uh and following that advice
um obviously none of us
a year ago could see what was happening
or when that when the school board's
association put that
memo out what the impact would be moving
forward
but i believe that most school districts
have been
extremely prudent in their use of funds
and not committing um you know
future obligations on behalf of local
taxpayers based on that advice that they
receive
are there further questions from mr
fruit school board association nope
okay thank you very much thank you
no we have missed representative luno
is last um we had scott marion but
he has not been in the meeting today so
that's
it okay where we're going next uh with
this discussion is that
we do have three amendments here i'm
going to start out first with the
amendment
uh you you should have received this one
from
uh house committee services
uh or from uh
it's uh amendment 10 10h
it was written by the department of
education as
my name at the top of it so this is
an amendment which deals with third
grade reading
stores and also it
identifies with all the issues which we
talked about today
taking the higher of the abm accounts
you based on either 2018-19
or the 2021 uh years
[Music]
mark do you have a little bit of
information you can share with us come
some of the rationale for
this particular amendment yep so
um for the the third grade reading
differential aid component
of the adequacy formula um we use
testing assessment data and so in the
spring of 2019
we have really clean what we call normal
data
in the spring of 2020 the assessment was
waived so we have
we don't have data and then going
forward if we look at 20
this spring coming up it's unclear
there's uncertainty about how good the
data is going to be
with the assessment this spring um what
the participation will be
we don't know um so what this amendment
does is to when we do the calculation
for fiscal year 22
um we'll have uh what the intent of this
legislation likely is is
to have clean data to look at um so
that's what this fix seeks to do
thank you very much mark so everybody in
the committee you have an opportunity to
ask mark question if you want at this
point in time basically
it's going to look at the higher of the
abma counts and that's most likely going
to be
2018-19 that would be basing on a future
okay with that and rick yes
yeah and and that would apply
specifically to the third grade reading
that's correct part of differentiating
yes
okay so what i'd like to do next is
we'll take these
uh uh amendments in uh numerical order
so you have both of them why don't you
start out reps
with uh your first one no great great
thanks very much
um and and if it's okay with the um with
the chair i'll probably
you know talk about one then the other
and then sort of
um look at the um the fiscal impact
of um of both of them um
but i do have that broken out um
separately so
um so thanks very much mr chair and
members of the committee
um bringing forward um uh two amendments
the first one being um uh amendment 2020
1012 h and uh i believe
um i sent sort of an advanced copy out
to members of the committee
last evening followed up with with uh
with another email this morning
um what uh what 1012h
does is restores the the fiscal capacity
disparity equitable grant which was a
part of the
the fy 21 school funding package uh
as included in the um the
the current um uh biennium uh budget
uh under house bill 4. and um what the
amendment does
is a couple things it uh it extends
the um that uh fiscal disparity
grant through the rest of the current
biennium
fy 22 and fy23
and it also updates the parameters used
to calculate
this grant based upon the fact that
that the department of revenue
administration
has uh has updated information on on
property values statewide
and and so just to briefly describe what
the
uh what the grant does is uh is it
provides a little
additional um state dollars um
about 50 million dollars in total um to
um to school districts by virtue of
their uh
member municipalities
that that basically have lower than
state average uh property that equalized
property valuation per pupil
and and its property valuation times
property tax rate obviously that
that generates some you know tax dollars
used to
fund public schools so when as as dr
kaskadin was saying when when you've got
communities that only have
30 percent of their or for 35 of their
properties
you know as taxable properties uh it um
it suppresses total property valuation
and communities like that you know tend
to have to work
and when i say work i mean pay property
tax rates
that are that are between three and in
some cases 10 times
higher than um than other
towns across the state so so
the um the fiscal capacity disparity
equitable grants like i said it's about
50 million dollars in total
same as it is in fy 21 are directed
to these communities that just have to
work super hard
harder than than most um to um
uh to generate the local um the local uh
tax dollars or the yeah the local
revenues they need
to uh to to fund their their public
schools
and um and districts can use them you
know uh you know ways they want i mean
some of them need to need to put it
towards property tax relief
some of them as as dr prue was saying uh
are putting it towards
one-time expenses and others have to put
it towards operating expenses
i mean these are all things that school
districts um uh deal with
and um but it's
uh you know it's it's uh
it's directing state dollars to where
they're needed most
the um uh the second the next amendment
is um restores the the second
part of the equitable grants that were
included in the uh
uh in the uh uh 20 20 21
um state budget and uh and so this
is um amendment number uh uh 1020h
and uh the second grant is tied to
uh concentrations of um of
uh higher concentrations of free and
reduced price lunch
um student population and so as um
as mr mclanch was was talking about
there's um there's a very well
understood and strong correlation
between the uh the the cost of education
and um and higher uh concentrations
of of students who live in um low
socioeconomic
uh conditions and so what uh what this
grant
does is uh as opposed to the other one
which was sort of a
taxpayer equity and student equity this
is squarely a student equity
type of um uh type of grant and again
direct some uh directs approximately 11
to 12 million dollars
statewide to districts that have
um uh higher uh percentages
of of students that come from low
socioeconomic backgrounds
uh helps those districts address those
higher costs
that uh that they have and as the chair
was um
was was also you know mentioning uh
earlier during the uh
during the hearing um there's a very
strong correlation
uh between um between you know
poverty uh low social social economic
status
i believe um rick also talked about
property valuations and student outcomes
and um and you know like like i think a
lot of us
you know feel we've got uh we've got a
lot to be proud of when it comes to
public education
in the granite state but unfortunately
it's just not everywhere and uh and so
being able to
direct state dollars to where they're
needed most
is um it's good for students and it's
good for property taxpayers
and um next i would
so so everybody's got copies of these
two amendments right
we're good we're good on that um i
wanted to
i wanted to sort of uh move forward to
um
to uh a report that was
prepared by the office of the
legislative budget assistant
and it's dated november 24th 2020 and
it's
it's preliminary and um and you know
stuff may have wiggled around a little
bit
since then but but i think you know at
least as far as the um
the the grand um you know totals uh i
think it's really accurate but
it's a uh it's a town by town um
that shows what um what the
what the state grant um is to
school districts in fy 21
so the current year um versus what they
would be in
fy 22 based on current law
and and statewide you can see that the
the state grant for public schools
goes down by nearly 90 million dollars
and so
um uh senate bill 135 um
including the amendments is directed to
to to you know closing this this
gap and what senator hennessey uh was
talking about during the introduction
is a big part of this gap you know about
about
35 40 percent of it uh is due to
artificially suppressed enrollment
numbers the adma numbers
due to the pandemic so so being able to
rely
on on fall 29 the greater fall night
2019 or fall 2020 is going to make a lot
of difference
for um uh for school districts and um
and that gets you about well i think
what what senator hennis
hennessey said is about 45 million
dollars so
um so it gets you it gets you you know
maybe not quite
halfway uh to this it also includes
about 12 million of that 45 about 12
million dollars
is uh is a statutory index um
uh increase in in cost that are applied
to
the base adequacy uh numbers and the
differentiated aid
numbers so um so senate bill 135
is introduced get you part of the way
there you know
about a well you know if you roll back
the cost index
gets you about a third of the way there
these two amendments
get you the rest of the way there and
and
and that's what i want to sort of draw
your your
uh your attention to next so so the lba
shows the 90 million dollar deficit and
um
and uh and now we get to uh now we get
to a luno spreadsheet
so this is not an official um
uh lba spreadsheet i i certainly don't
want to represent it
as as being anything other than just for
comparison purposes
just so that we can sort of see um uh
uh what um what these two amendments
would cost
but uh does everybody have a copy you
know what i'm referring to right now
it's a spreadsheet i think it says sb
135 with amendments for equitable grants
for comparison purposes
only uh sent it out last night again
this morning
and uh and uh like the lba spreadsheet
it's a town by town
and in the um in the
the uh the first part of the spreadsheet
is uh is taken right from uh department
of education data
you can see the two columns for the um
uh 2019 um adma
the the 2020 adma and then um
uh the similar things for the free and
reduced price launch adma
and uh from 20 from
2019 and and again from 2020
you can see how it selects the higher of
the two
for each of those categories so this is
taking us right through
senate bill 135 is passed in the senate
and then moving to the right hand side
of the spreadsheet
you can see the uh the two red columns
uh are the are the equitable grants for
free and
reduced price lunch uh for fy21
and that comes to a little under uh 12
million dollars 11.73
million dollars and then the fy 21
um equitable grant for physical capacity
disparity aid
uh which comes to 47.5 million dollars
um so all together it's about 60 million
dollars
and both those grants disappear on
june 30th of of this year so that's 60
million dollars that our school
districts
will um uh will lose in equitable grants
again equitable grants
um to improve student equity and
taxpayer equity
in um in uh in districts that
that need it most and um
and and then you can see in the two blue
columns
right next to each what um what the
amendment
um 1020h does in terms of um
restoring and extending the free and
reduced price lunch
equitable grant you know it's funny
going down through it i mean i just
applied the my the formula calculations
are sort of at the top of the column
and and it comes down nearly dollar for
dollar
um for what was um was was in the doe
uh report so so that made me feel really
good that i actually got the formula
right in my spreadsheet
um uh on the um on the
the next two columns you can see
something similar
with the um with the fiscal uh capacity
um
equitable grant uh we the the amendment
does update some of the parameters uh in
there
so um uh because uh based on
guidance that that mark i think
i think you gave me the guidance
yesterday that we'd probably be used
that the department would be using 2019
um equalized valuation data from the dra
so so obviously 2019 it's they're higher
valuations than than in 2018 so
so we updated um some of these
parameters from
from the low of 350 000 updated that to
and updated the high end from a million
to a million
fifty and um um and
it it comes in right around the same the
same price
tag i mean it's a little bit more but
but uh
um uh but obviously this is this is just
modeling these aren't final numbers
uh uh but uh but just to just just to
show
what what it would mean for for towns
and school districts across the state
so the way to read these is that those
red columns
that's what they're getting this year
and and
if the two amendments aren't uh aren't
passed
then they would get zero
for fy22 and fy23 so
in some cases in some cases they might
get a little bit more
based on changes in valuation or free
and reduced price
launch in some cases they might get a
little bit less
so it's not a perfect um
[Music]
it's not identical to what it was in fy
but it's it's formula driven it's very
close and if we don't do something like
it the answer is zero
so so you know um and
you know rick's heard me say it a
million times
i hope we all agree that that when
looking at town by towns
you need to use some discipline and not
just go to your town
first but to see what's happening in
manchester see what's happening in
berlin
see what's happening in pittsfield uh
how about
you know newport um which is 10 miles up
the road from 15 miles up the road from
where i'm sitting right now
uh in claremont and um and and see what
it means for
um for those those most you know
districts that have some of the highest
challenges across the state whether
that's in um
property valuation or or poverty or both
and um um you know and do that first and
then turn to your own
um you know home district uh too because
i you know i understand that's important
um anyway finally what
what um what i want to uh mention
is um is that uh
all of this follows on the
heavily bipartisan work that
done during the last session where where
in particular
representative ladd and i worked um
worked very closely together
in in developing this package of
equitable grants the free and reduced
price lunch grant
as part of amendment 1020
the fiscal capacity disparity equitable
grant
as part of you know what's contained in
amendment 1012
and um and and uh we we
put these things into back then it was
called house bill 709
in 2019 and um and it passed our
committee
um strong bipartisan vote um ought to
pass
on a vote of 17-2 came to the floor of
the house
passed 262 to 82 and
and um and so you know these are these
are
this is a package that that that i hope
can continue to be unifying in terms of
our recognition
of of the need for the state to support
its public schools um in particular
schools that have the um
the highest amount of need and um
and uh and then i you know uh
i i guess i'll sort of wrap up uh uh
things there i know i know people
probably have questions well where's the
the money gonna come from um first of
all i think there's a policy decision
for the house education committee
um but uh but you know if you're looking
about where the money's gonna come from
um uh house ways and means just up the
uh revenue estimate
um uh uh last week
increased it by 134 million dollars
uh have not allocated that anyway in
fact i think it's all allocated to the
to the rainy day fund there's a
estimated surplus in the education trust
fund of between 21 and 44 million
dollars
uh come the end of this school year so
um i i have confidence that the funds
are there
i have confidence that uh property
taxpayers are going to want to
want to see this done and i think it's
in the best interest of students in our
state
thank you very much representative um i
just want to check in a few words that
when we're looking at these amendments
i'm looking at them in terms
of policy considerations right now
um if you were to look for example at uh
and then at 10 12 that's uh i believe
the one that
someone will spoke to first dealing with
the physical capacity disparity
you're going to see some numbers there
where we're talking about influx
evaluation
property valuations we we've
batted these numbers around over the
last several years in fact we even
batted around
earlier this year in hb 608
where this fiscal capacity type formula
was within that bill uh we just didn't
have
know the the time to play with numbers
and try to get it right uh but
i i know there are a few differences
here when we're looking at
you know where you know i see in 10 12
it's 420 000 or less property valuation
uh we've seen others before which spent
600 000
or less valuation and going up to
another upper level where
it cuts off usually it's over a million
bucks when
1.1 1.14 this one breaks off at
a little over one so
the policy is that we recognize and
understand that there are districts out
there that need
support that are unable to raise us
locally and to remain and eliminate the
disparities
in inequities that was one of the uh
rationale or policy decisions we put in
also hb 242 which went over to
the out of this committee and went
to a second committee 242
mentions physical capacity disparity
right within it
so we're all recognizing that we need to
do something
with this so uh i don't know if i
necessarily agree with all the figures i
haven't had a chance to play with the
figures yet
but i that the policy here is accurate
it's for it's and i've sat down and
talked with mark earlier this year
regarding this type of formula and and
uh so we've done that earlier um
and in regard to the
one-time money that we're talking about
there with the free and reduced and the
uh the uh device property valuation
uh that comes up to write a little a
little over 59
59.2 call it you know whatever 60
million dollars
that is uh money which has
allowed some of the districts to do what
they need to do
but it also is created to eliminate
those disparities and we do know there's
a relationship
between you know achievement and and
poverty
the question i have for you rexella luno
is that we also recognize that there's
inequities and disparities even amongst
some communities that have the
wherewithal
so how do we account for those like we
tried to do in 242 and i don't know if
that has
all the answers in it but we tried to
identify how to support a school
district
that might even be a a district which
keeps us swept
or or but they also we know have pockets
of 30 percent of the kids are
not functioning at a level do they get a
support
to in those disparities within those
districts is oftentimes between
subgroups within the district um
which uh that's where we need to really
improve within this entire state
so that question's for you dave yeah no
i'd be happy to take that thanks very
much
um rick for for laying that out um
but and and and that's that's actually
what the um what the
the house bill i'm sorry the amendment
um 10
20 h uh contemplate so this is the the
uh free and reduced price lunch um
equitable grant
and if you go to the page six of that
spreadsheet
um the luno spreadsheet um you'll
you'll see and i'm just going to pick on
one of our beautiful lakes region
uh towns wolfeboro and um and
you know there's an excess swept town uh
they're
they're they're not obviously receiving
any fiscal capacity disparity grant
but you can see that at least based on
the the model
um that that i ran on this
because of their uh almost 29
free and reduced price lunch student
population
of the of the 700 students they would
receive an additional 42
000 um in um in an equitable grant
um and and
that's consistent with what we did in
house bill 709
and it's consistent with um with what uh
what we're proposing
thank you are there questions now from
the committee representatives
thank you um i went and i was looking at
berlin
because we had been talking about berlin
and i'm noticing that they actually have
an
increase in students but they lose about
two million dollars and i'm wondering
i'm i'm looking at
um both
sets according to yours they increase in
students and according to the
estimated um one from the state they're
losing about two million dollars
and i'm wondering if i'm wondering how
much of that
is um law their loss of their estimate
of free and reduced
students and how much of that is because
of the
additional one-time aid
um that you that is included in that
great great thank you for the for the
question uh representative lucas
so um so looking at at the
the lba um spreadsheet you can see
as you've pointed out berlin loses
approximately
two million dollars in in-state aid
and then if you go back to the luno
spreadsheet
and look and look at berlin you can see
that
that 1.6 million dollars
of that of that 2 million is from the
uh the equitable fiscal capacity um
grant and another 210
000 is from the free and the enhanced
uh equitable free and reduced price
lunch grant so of that two million
dollars
about 1.85 million of that
is due to the grants that um that these
two
amendments would restore thank you
further questions it's a discussion
okay i know it kind of diverts away from
our hearing process
but we had nobody else there for the
hearings and
i think that folks needed to have this
explanation
uh we've been battling this particular
issue
for years
[Music]
and uh we are because the pandemic
it's really hastening the need to
recognize
that it's got to be fixed somehow here
rick thanks um i i think it might be i
mean
we are sort of blending hearing with
work session
right now and i really appreciate that
um uh given the importance of
and the timeliness of this but i was
wondering if we could talk a little bit
about
how a um multiple amendments
um can be considered by a committee
and what that results in and if maybe we
could even get
get uh mark to weigh in on the
uh compatibility of these three
amendments with each other
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
just going to close this hearing
and then from that we'll go into a
discussion
uh on on on what we have in front of us
on sb 135 and
and we're not going to take any action
because i i think there's a lot of
questions folks need to be considering
and looking at here
so i'm at this point in time i am not
seeing any other folks to testify i'm
closing down the hearing for 135
and opening up right now what was
the account there you have that uh
representative shop for the
number of people have signed in and
support our post
that we could mention that for reps and
uh okay
uh so there were rep shaw
maybe you could just double check my
figures we had 389 in support
yeah six opposed
zero neutral and we had originally
scheduled
seven to testify but we had
if you include the two from the school
from the department of education
and dr corrine
that would be 10.
thank you very much that right rickshaw
yeah i counted two of them together
okay i did not see dr casscan in
is it um aaron hennessey
leslie want scott marion did not
testify but he had scheduled to testify
jeff mick lynch david luno carl ladd
did not testify but jerry fru did
and two from the department and current
uh doctor
kes i missed her last name did you get
that john goldberg
yes have that one as well
okay so we've got a number there what's
it just
eight nine seven uh
we're in the ball okay folks we got it
down in the record here
let's discuss finances so
this this hearing is closed and now i'm
opening it up to the discussion as
a committee the whole to be looking at
uh and discussing uh the school funding
issue associated with 135
okay uh is there a discussion amongst
anybody here
yes represent bones you mentioned we
have
[Music]
we give
uh
i've talked with him just you know prior
to this and he's going to be requesting
that
right off here um so
uh i think that yeah if we're going to
do something we're going to have to kind
yeah so so thanks rick i you know i
think that was
i think what what what what ralph's
asking was sort of
um along the lines of what um what what
i was sort of putting up
um a little while ago which is
the the steps forward for the committee
for for for a committee when it's facing
multiple amendments
and what what um because i think you can
vote on the amendment
so i know we're not going to exact today
um but
but but at after after
a committee has has approved multiple
amendments
doesn't that then create a committee
amendment one
one merged amendment yes that's what i
understand we do have the clerk
online here with us right now is paul
smith there
uh uh i believe that the clerk that you
see in our meeting is actually
rep shaw's workstation
[Music]
okay
16 and 16a
it's on three different amendments and
they all say a different thing
they all say something different before
you know
okay um on the first one
on 10 12 it says
down to line 26 paragraph
1 of section 236 of this actually
june 30th 2021 and then
line 27 says uh
paragraphs two and three of this section
uh this actually i'll take it back to 30
20 23. and if you look at
10 13 and then you look at 10 20
they all say something different for
that
so barbara what you've picked up on is
the
the the the
the most complicated part of of these
two amendments
because they refer to statutes that are
in current law
have repeals repeal dates
of of of 6 30 20 2021
and each of the two amendments has to be
able to stand on their own
so so um so
the the fiscal capacity disparity
amendment
so 1012 h
allows the repeal to stand
on the free and reduced price lunch part
but extends the repeal date on the
on the fiscal capacity disparity piece
to 630 2023
on the other hand amendment 1020h
does exactly the the opposite it allows
the
the fiscal capacity disparity
provision in current law to sunset
on 6 30 2021 but extends the free and
reduced price lunch
statute through 630 2023
and so the repeal language is a little
funky um
uh in getting that right we i spent a
lot of time with ols
yesterday uh and mary ellen working
working on
on this to make sure we got it right uh
the the most important part though is
if the committee were to uh
approve uh these two amendments all
three amendments
let's say then then the
then th that the amendments are
basically the amendment 10 10 12 h
would would would extend the
the fiscal capacity disparity grant
language
through 630 2023 amendment 1020h
would extend the free and reduced price
lunch grant
through um through 6 30 20
23 and the committee amendment would
reflect
both of those um um you know merged
elements
barbara also referred to 1013h which i
sent over last night
and i sent it over with it with a with a
note saying that
that it still had an error in the in the
repeal language
1020h corrects that
so the the two amendments in play here
that i've brought forward
are 10 12 10 20 and then you've got 10
10.
that's going to be another decision 13
is gone
13 is gone
several people here didn't have that i
was wondering
okay so um i guess the next step for us
there is some necessity regardless how
do we do this thing
that we try to get to finance as quickly
as possible
however obviously there is gonna have to
be some
working with ols here and with
uh dale v8 um
so uh and i planned on not having any
sessions or anything
next week i was just gonna have folks
have you know a week
off which would be kind of pleasant and
then the following week of course we're
into uh three days of session
down in bedford so the
the next time we can really get to and
address this thing would be most likely
you know almost like two weeks two full
so that's looking at a time frame there
um and i think we do need to work on
these right here before we can go any
so any comments from the community out
there remember
the hole i'm glad luis andrews has had
thank you mr chair i have one question
which i
i don't know the answer and maybe we'll
have to look into
i understand the state of new hampshire
is going to receive
somewhere around 350 million dollars
for school districts and i'm wondering
if any of that
can be applied to this that we're
looking
to get from the taxpayers thank you
that's a question we've asked on so many
other types of top topics too
in regards to you know ear handling
devices etc
in schools i don't know if we have
clear well we do have we did get from
caitlin some definition of how the
s or moneys can be used um
they they it was specific it happened
about a page and a half
of options you can use it for it's
pretty wide open
however i i don't have an answer for you
on it right now
um whether someone is going to be used
to supplement parts of our formula i
of course that's i don't think so
personally
and i think that we've got to be very
careful when we do that too
and the issue from a policy perspective
not
speaking as a principle of a school
that funding schools on a one-time basis
makes it
very very difficult to plan in terms of
your
labor your your your teachers your paris
teacher aides whatever you want to call
them it's just almost
impossible to plan year to year and have
a long-range plan
and effect so it's wise not to use
one-time monies
in your basic formula that you have here
adequacy is one thing we're talking
items right here
which are apart from adequacy their uh
fiscal class maternity leave etc was
apart from in addition to it comes out
part of a formula but it's not part of
atticus
so i don't have an answer for you
representing ambrose on that
it's a good question um i doubt very
seriously that we're going to be
we should consider those monies as part
of our what we're doing in supporting of
schools
i think that's a supplemental amount of
money
we have a hand raised from uh there you
have your hand on mark
thanks uh thanks for the question um
the the 350 million going out that's
going to go
directly to the schools under a federal
formula
so it's already the federal the federal
government will decide the allocation
um the state will do the allocation but
um the fed will
determine what that allocation
methodology is going to be essentially
so that money's already going to the
schools
just to clarify that's especially
mentioned to us earlier yes
your neighborhood listen remember the
ladder thank you
listen to you talk about the uh date
uh perhaps next week often the following
week uh
invested just for a modification
what is the drop dead date that this
these amendments and this document has
to be
completed so it could be acted on in
this
next budget well there there's
for the house bills to drop that date
almost
but for for the senate bills which are
just arriving which we don't even have
yet it's much later uh however
then there's another date too is the
date for
finance to have the bills out on the
house floor
and hb one and two if we miss that
we'll end up having to use a bill that
morris
you know like that's been done
previously uh with a three or four hp
three or four
and and uh i don't think we want to go
down that route
i think we need to try to rectify this
on the outside as soon as possible
finance i believe is acting
next i don't have a date right now does
anybody out there have that date
monday monday and tuesday i think
i i thought it was yeah a little later
yeah tuesday i think
but but that's right on us and
and so this is why when we talk about
things like the merger of the university
system and that they're looking for
amendments there
and there's uh that's unresolved uh
so they're very very busy putting this
hd2 together
this would be um
this has policy but it also has you know
a
you know it has some figures in there
right now and those of course the page
figures
so but we're at the deadline we're there
thank you representative and sixth is
the last
sentence okay
i was just told the sixth is the last
day to report
seth bill is going through a second
committee
may 6th may 76 may right
so we have time
thanks again yes
yeah my battery went out and um
represent uh leon isn't here to plug
into his extension cord
anyway looking at
the two amendments um 10
and 12 i do not have a problem with
except for
you know line 26 27 i haven't looked at
that
because i mean our town like a lot of
towns have just been finished in the
evaluation
so our valuation is increased
so that helps i i've been trying to find
out what it is right now
and with our population to see how we
fall into that
uh but i do i mean other than
the 1020h is
again looking at paragraph two and
paragraph one and three and whatnot
i haven't looked at that but i've no
problem with the
increasing the equal evaluation for
people
okay did you hear that rexella
that um
you you you had a concern with 10 28
no other than yeah other than the no
yeah yeah and other than i mean i
haven't looked at the language on
comparison with you know all those
amendments on
paragraph one of 236 and paragraph two
and three or 236
on how they interplay and so that's the
only concern i have
you know again yeah that that that was
that that was the complex part in these
in these amendments and i had to go back
we had to go back to hb4
from 2019 um uh
and um and paragraph 236 which was
repeal
language uh from this and and like i
said it got sort of
it got sort of funky but um but
but we we got it um uh uh
we got it right through uh through ols
late yesterday and i'd be happy to um
to work with you offline ralph i can
send you the the pieces from hb4
and you can see how um i can look it up
i'm just
okay and just look one does one thing
one does the opposite
yeah yeah yeah but that why i mentioned
before why we need to
maybe combine is because depend on how
we take the amendments up
and what the result will be you know
if we do the one before the other then
yeah the the the intention is for for
all these amendments to be compatible
with each other so they can stand alone
okay there's there's several options
which we have here of course
we can't take action today uh i think
we'd be wrong in doing it but uh
we need to find out when uh this
information that we have would be best
uh the best serve the finance
in finance if they need to have this
right off
we could always have amendment meet
and do an amendment quickly sometime
next week i hate to do that
um but we could do that
and then uh uh we would uh
shoot it to them um it would probably go
up to the house floor and then uh you
know we have that discussion go to the
second
um any further discussion on this
anybody really objecting that we have to
come back
on let's say thursday of next week or
wednesday or not wednesday
not wednesday i get my second show you
rick got his yesterday you know i didn't
get mine yesterday
marine
yes yeah i want to put a shout out to
mark really for a great catch on that
third grade reading
yeah yeah so we're staying with 1819 huh
yeah yeah caitlyn actually um she said
she thought of it when she was brushing
her teeth the other day so
wait i'd like to know the name of that
toothpaste
[Laughter]
okay so um so i i think what we're going
to do is we're going to try
and get some amending language made here
tie it together and then if we can get
that together
then we see today is
uh today thursday
25th thursday thursday thursday
that will have to be worked out because
right at this point i'm nothing
scheduled for next week
but is there anybody that's going to
take a trip and be gone
next week thank you
you're going to go i'll be here in
california but i
you just don't mean yeah yeah maybe
yeah i'll adjust it's going the right
way though you wouldn't want to come
back this way and have to zoom like
in the morning sometimes i i have zoomed
before so what we'll do is we'll we'll
work on this and we'll get back to you
if we do have something scheduled for
next week
you can post several locations
so with that i don't think we have any
further uh to discuss or due today i
want to thank everybody for your
patience
this is never easy the cost of
okay thank you very much for closing
this work session down now and
we'll stay in thank you thank you
be well have a good weekend youtube